it's a true honor to be here and I'm
really excited I'm going to cover a lot
of ground so beware i'm famous for
giving six our talks in 20 minutes so
it's gonna be a lot of material pack
well not that much but um well anyway
this this opening slide really kind of
summarizes sort of the goal of my work
which is to say what if we could scoop
up all the world's information you know
all the open information around the
world and try to create essentially a
sort of a fusion visualization of what's
happening around the world how is that
differed to point one of the questions
earlier um what am I seeing here in
Washington how is that comparing to what
someone in Chicago and San Francisco is
seeing compared to what someone else
around the world is seeing I'm actually
um one of my recent collaborations with
I Rin which is the the one of the I
think was the former news agency of the
UN we've been doing a lot about the
Forgotten conflicts which is kind of
this notion of all these things around
the world they're happening that we've
never even heard of here in the US
because it's been going on for 30 years
and it's you know sort of people have
gotten people aren't interested in
anymore um so this is kind of the goal
and I'm going to talk a lot about what
does this mean how do you actually do
something like this oh and before just a
quick aside the work I'm actually going
to talk about today actually a few hours
ago was announced by a computer world as
one of the winners of their 2015 data
Editors Choice Awards so I'm very very
excited about this um so this kind of
gives you a little brief overview about
the type of work that I do and who I am
long story short this you know this is a
fraction of it you know everything from
mapping the text of wikipedia looking at
the geography of social media I'm
tracing the spread of ideas over books
looking at declassified State Department
cables digitizing the world's
constitutions extracting out the images
of the world's books and putting those
on flickr i tend to focus on really
massive projects you know how do we
truly reimagine how we understand
ourselves and the world around us
through data are you thinking about
today there's just so much data out
there what can we do this if we start
thinking outside the box and thinking
very creatively oh and what you're
seeing here is a very interesting map um
this is all the locations worldwide this
is by month Twitter over the lot from
january two thousand twelve to december
two thousand fourteen all the locations
that are showing at least two or more
tweets so it breaks up the wall into a
grid two or more tweets a month and out
of the out of this
api and what's really fascinating kind
of the areas that you're seeing high
amounts of Twitter usage oh and what's
fascinating is to open my so i did a
famous study back in two thousand twelve
the global twitter heartbeat which
really look at the geography of twitter
and how that was growing and what you
saw in 2012 was twitter is expanding
exponentially me it was it was on track
to cover the entire world oh and what
you see here is is so this this this
timeline in the lower left that's the
number of tweets from the the streaming
API a per month and you see it levels
off about 2030 min of 2013 oh and what
you see if you look closely the
geography you see kind of exponential
rise twitter is your spreading and then
it kind of pauses and then it kind of
resent r Eliza's internally this is very
important one of my one of my columns
that will be coming out soon from
foreign policy looks at the Yum any
conflict so the Yemen Saudi Arabia
conflict and shows that that's a
conflict that we're seeing so much
social media coverage about but it's
coming almost exclusively so the Saudi
Arabian side we're really not seeing the
Yemeni side of that conflict and this
comes out across the world on what you
see are Wow look at this there's a
conflict happy here and you know I can
turn the YouTube Twitter Facebook and
see everything is coming out of that
well you can see a lot but you're not
you know you're missing critical portion
of this so this is really sort of that
notion of um you know we're all sort of
very you know today things like
Twitter's the shiny new objects like wow
cool data said it's kind of API great
plug-in and I can I can generate great
things from it but to sort of caution
and say well you know oftentimes you
know you have to really think about
what's the data showing me um this is an
interesting map this is comparing the
month of March of this year all
locations mentioned in BBC coverage in
all locations mentioned in the New York
Times what's interesting about this so
orange BBC green New York Times or you
can see that there's actually BBC seems
to have a much greater reach in a lot of
areas of the world the New York Times
and you see the New York Times kind of
has this flash what kind of puts
everything out based on its old print
cycle on BBC of course you know have
somewhat of an unfair advantage somebody
because they still operate bureaus
across the world where is the new york
time to sort of retrenched a little bit
and the BBC offers so many different
language versions including our thai
language version and so but we're so
fast thing about this is in American
academic literature communications and
political science in particular the New
York Times is the outlet that's use are
the try and catalog of the world and
what this suggests is that you know
you're getting
very skewed view of the world you know
no basically is very interesting and do
visualizations like this because
intrinsically you kind of think well the
New York Times all the news that's fit
to print we also recognize that there's
a lot that isn't in there but to be able
to visualize that and be able to say
well you know really you need to at
least add BBC into here if you're trying
to reach for example you know sort of a
lot of the eastern part of the world I'm
sure its ability to the ability to black
out of screen it totally froze ah there
we go all right outsmarted by a USB
remote so anyway so this is really the
goal so my project is really about so
the genome project which I run is
supported by booboo ideas it's really
about how do we try to catalog the
world's information so take the world's
open information in sixty five languages
live Trent live machine translate all
that in real time and try to attract
what's happening around the world who's
involved the emotions the themes the
imagery the context to crank try and
create essentially a graph over human
society it's a small goal i know very
small oh and really this is kind of
prompted by the idea that today we've
got satellites in space and sensors in
the ground that can tell you an
earthquake anywhere in the world within
seconds and you know all this detail
about it but what if you want to know
tell me every protests happening right
now on this earth every protest
worldwide how many people involved what
are they processing about and how is the
public reacting to that we really
haven't had data like that to be able to
observe the natural world um but all the
pieces are in place you've got news
media and most areas of the world you
have social media now you have all these
all these data streams that exist how do
we pull those all together so the genome
project you can imagine sort of every
moment second by second trying to you
can imagine essentially scooping up a
large fraction print broadcast of web
from around the world this enormous fire
hose of media coming in I'm adding in
books and academic literature and all
these other things I'll talk about in a
second so this is massive fire hose of
information coming in anything that's
not english goes over here and gets live
machine translation I'll come to that in
a second sixty five languages so largest
deployment of streaming machine
translation where the accuracy is
modulated based on how much how much raw
data is coming in um see you Matt so all
this stuff gets translated um and then
process it and two things happen one it
goes through it tries to understand what
tically happened here so in this
particular case we see an article that
tells us well two things happened here
Iraq diplomatically criticized Turkey
the reason for that was because turkey
bonkers militants so taking that text
and trying to understand about 300
categories that what physically happened
here also being able to catalogue
protest etc the other side of that then
we shall come down to is okay so this
happened well you know who's involved
how's the world feed them out is the
world saying Iraq was good for
criticizing Turkey are they sing turkeys
the better you know party in this how is
the world kind of reacting how is that
vary across the world um so there's 300
million events right now 300 categories
around the world going back to 79 this
is an example what you can do kind of
map out for example Nigeria each of
these little dots is representing some
event that took place and so you can
basically make animation for that map in
the upper right that was Ukraine just
before the president fled and actually
if you zoom in it was really interesting
it showed Crimea really turning against
you saw all the pieces in place in DC a
lot of people were saying look you know
the president just signed a peace deal
the protesters they're already
dispersing Ukraine is now at peace and I
don't think that was intelligence
failure i think that was seen a
politician seeing the world through
rose-colored glasses but this is very
powerful to be able to say well look you
know we've got local meeting there this
reporting they're pulling all police
forces out of neighboring areas and
moving in this the government obviously
is believing something bad is about to
happen here they don't believe peace is
happening and so or vice versa simply
having that much force is entering an
area is potentially going to cause some
issues I'm so being able to look at bill
the map things out bill do things like
this top map this is actually percentage
of events that G don't monitors from
worldwide media that are relating the
protest so sort of a protest intensity
and so you can see around the Arab
Spring you can see you sort of ebbs and
flows you can see well yes post-arab
spring there are more protests being
reported worldwide but actually this
pales in comparison to what we saw in
the 80s the map at the bottom is Ukraine
so it's drilling down and trying to
understand protest trends gotta pee so
be coming out soon looking at this
across Europe and understanding how
fragile the EU really is based on the
enormous differences and how the how the
EU societies are used to dealing with
societal tension or things like economic
hardship so of course you have this
event dear so what's physically
happening around the world but what's
often interesting is you just want to
know about media coverage for example on
this top graph using the television
collection that Roger was talking about
um so this is the number of
mentions in television news that they
monitor about Ebola and so you can see
for example that you know thousands of
people were dying in Africa zero
coverage it wasn't until the wh 0 you
know says now we have a real crisis here
just a little blip wasn't until the
first Americans get it that oh my God
we're all going to die and this is
actually newsworthy now and this tells
us something really important about you
know what are Americans thinking about
what's happening over there and then the
tone of that the emotion of that and
this I can't remember if this was the
ane a camera which dictionary um was
used for this but what this shows
actually is a slant towards positivity
and actually as part of one of my pic
coms actually walk through CNN's
coverage over this entire time every
single article in CNN over time and what
you saw was very fascinating is you saw
literally that inflection point there
where the news becomes more positive the
original the first CNN article was oh my
god it's you know 99 percent without a
it's a death sentence that comes over
here we're all going to die the whole
country is going to die it'll be the
plague oh and then what you saw him was
when those first Americans get it and
that miracle cure comes out then you saw
look it's modern medicine to the rescue
America is here now we will save you all
there's nothing to worry about now and
then you tell all this coverage about
medicine and all these cures and Ebola
isn't scary anymore um this is really
really fascinating to be able to see
that because again you know
intrinsically you kind of if you were
watching the news to kind of sense that
but to be able to actually plot that and
see this was the inflection point and
this lines up with when you know the
Americans got it so really trying to
understand you know what are we really
seeing in the news what is the news
really telling us um this was a piece
kind of looking at structure so this my
father is one of the future gen
scientists so carbon sequestration clean
energy and so on so one things we did is
we looked at five years of english
language coverage of carbon
sequestration I'll pulled out all the
people names and who's appearing with
whom it turns out this cluster is very
interesting these communities in
particular what you're seeing is sort of
what what basically what names co-occur
with what names in news coverage and a
lot and it all makes sense but what's
very interesting is around the fringes
of each of them you see the reporters
and the analysts that are involved like
The Wall Street analysts she start kind
of understanding we r you know for
example you know relating to say the
british conservative view on carbon
sequestration the party or the reporters
that are primarily the ones that are
covering that sector so you really start
understanding we're the viewpoints that
people are seeing who are sort of the
the gatekeepers to how people understand
these various
sectors of things and this was a piece i
did for FP this was most of 2013 all the
names extracted out and put in a giant
graph this is the top 100 thousand names
and you know this is more wall art than
science this particular graph because
there's so much there but was it is you
actually zoom in you start seeing really
interesting connectivity about how
countries are connected you can actually
some of the countries you can actually
trace out their military hierarchy
because you see what names co-occur with
the president and then on downwards you
see really really fascinating things
that being to look at the world scale
this was a single day of global coverage
of the Mexican drug cartels what are all
the locations that are mentioned
alongside the Mexican drug cartels turns
out the the day that this news media was
from this actually matched DEA zone maps
very very closely you see the transit
corridors and everything so again kind
of a very powerful way to say well
what's the geographic footprint and that
we see in the media and does this
reflect the noon reality of this this is
a very interesting study with I Rin this
is media fatigue so this is basically
it's a normalized escale but this is
basically the Nepal earthquake and then
the venue at two vanuatu cyclo or
typhoon what you saw here is basically
sort of intensity of cover so you see
very little coverage it shoots up and
then you see a base in Nepal or starting
vanuatu you see a larger shoot up and
because again you saw you knew that that
was coming down the road but what you
see is very fascinating is you see that
really within a single week you've lost
most of that interest of coverage and
within two weeks you've pretty much lost
the interest and what's interesting is
this actually now it turns out this
particular this exact timeline follows
from many many disasters that we've
looked at and again people in journalism
understand media fatigue but being on
the map that precisely was most
interesting is this bottom graph this
actually looked at the domestic media by
country it shows that that graph
actually follows across countries so
even countries that are nearby they're
not covering it longer it's basically
traffic cycle this really tells you what
things like natural disasters you have a
very very short window where you know
people watching here you think about
Haiti you know what's the latest that's
you know from 2010 earthquake what's the
latest in Haiti today you know how are
things going how is rebuilding going in
each part of the country most people
don't know because the media is long ago
forgotten about haiti so sentiment
analysis so the question of course is
you know what is the center people
always want to know tone about things
and of course you know as roger was
pointing out you know that's a huge
issue sarcasm is
especially different parts of the world
symbolism and all these things mean
different things so the goal here is to
say well what if we take you know all of
the major so right now over 24 think is
actually now up to 28 or 29 now
basically take every open dictionary or
dictionary that I can get permission to
use basically apply them all so right
now over 4,500 emotions and themes are
coated from every single article on the
goal is to basically say what if we take
every sentiment dictionaries out there
and run every article through all of
those then we can start understanding
well do some of these seem to reflect a
more because what you see is they they
tend to line up a certain areas and then
maybe I virgin other areas so the
buildings are the first time to actually
see this on there the literature split
about half the literature says
translation if you translate a document
say from arabic and english and run it
through an english dictionary that that
you know that that is not meaningful
that loses the the emotion another
portion of literature says absolutely
total preservation no change at all um
there just hasn't been much work at this
so what happens if we basically try this
you know what can we see from this I'm
so every article you have everything
from anxiety the smug so these aren't
just positive negative these are all
because you know psychology then i'll
talk about positive negative they talk
about all these you know etonic signals
and all these things I'm so trying to
run it through all these different
dictionaries and also foreign language
dictionaries so things like ml santacon
which is aiming for the Spanish language
is the Spanish adaptation of a new so
the idea is to say well what happens if
we especially if we have dictionaries
that our base for language well if we
take a spanish document run it through
spanish anew and then we run it through
the english a new the base one do we see
identical how much is translation
affecting us and does that affect us
more in certain areas in others so kind
of building a base that we can
understand a motion through this on this
was the television archive of plotting
this is through positivity no sorry this
is the anxiety from regressive imagery
dictionary and you can see all the way
there that in the towards the end that
huge jump that was the government
shutdown so of course you know the huge
fear that my god the government shutting
down and this is entry one so this is a
Assad of Syria and what you're seeing is
positively negativity here it turns out
if you actually kind of trace this out
these these ups and downs actually
follow quite closely with interstates
they actually slightly lead his behavior
so you see if a tone is collapsing just
after that tends to be one he tends to
do things now that's not reflecting in
fact that he's watching the news me and
saying god everyone's upset with me now
I should do something is reflecting that
the news media is capturing the fact
that you know he's being boxed into a
corner he
and then he wins and then next thing
happens so it's really interesting if we
try to start playing out the
correlations of this with behavior the
mass translation so right now a 65
languages represents 98.4 percent of
what we see worldwide this is it doing
with slaying alternative names these are
all the languages here obviously you
know quality of things like Russian so
Philip Kron who's one of the fathers of
Moses which is one of the big tool kits
we use his Russian engine by permission
obviously that's a lot more accurate
than say Swahili where there simply are
very very few resources that are
available for that so again though the
goal is what happens when we translate
all the stuff you see wildly different
views so this is blue so this is Yemen
blue is English read our what's being
discussed in the Arabic language press
and you see there are some similarities
and major areas but a huge difference
there as well and in fact this is from a
particular day now if you actually roll
forward more recently on the checkpoints
a lot of the death squads that are
occurring are exclusively being reported
in Arabic language press the American or
English language press even BBC are not
really reaching into those areas so of
course the news media is only one
element of things so what happens if we
take for example Amnesty International
their entirety of their publications
back back to nineteen sixty put that in
the map when we see the geographic
footprint we can drill into here and say
well you know where's a particular
torture mechanism user where what kind
of known from these you know basically
sort of because the news tells us what's
happening now why it's happening on this
earth academic literature project this
is collaboration of the US Army JSTOR
with permission of JSTOR we were able to
process the entirety of their holdings
back to nineteen forty-five of academic
literature of all the major social
science and humanities journals dtic and
then of course the Internet Archive
their 1.7 billion PDFs skin those skin
the URLs of those four things that look
like academic literature then anything
is still living process that what you're
seeing here is the geographic footprint
of these and what's interesting is we
can take topics like food security and
actually map that through and say what
are all the locations there discussed in
the academic literature about food
security and scholars can look at this
and say well yes yes yes I see well boy
there's no one's really talked about
food security in this area this is an
area that we know is a problem but no
one's really talked about in that area
and then you can drill down to the
citation graph and say who's the most
heavily excited who's an expert so the
reason the Army's interested in this is
this is the nation-building arm of the
army
actually build schools and just other
things so they can go in and say for
example we want to build a school here
the geology is great but what are the
social cultural issues here you know is
this an area where women and men are not
allowed to be educated is a certain area
you know is this tribe not allowed to
cross over this border so this is the
ability you know you think about one of
the challenges is that social cultural
issues so here in the US um you know you
know we have a separation of church and
state we have a lot of these separations
a lot of parts of world cultural ethnic
religious connections have intense
intense impact and that's very foreign
to a lot of Western now so being able to
you know it's not that no one's ever
known anything I mean these areas have
been enormously well stay they have
their own incredible literature's and
we've you know historically we've not
sort of look at this so what happens
when we process all this material be
able to look at all these different
things another project UN OSHA standby
task force qcr I and some others every
time does natural disaster curls
worldwide when the UN declares as a
disaster immediately we begin a feed of
everything that we see worldwide about
that disaster we provide a feat
including all the imagery that's in all
this coverage right now humans then go
through and manually tag all that
imagery and right now we've been part of
a matter of mine very interested in
talking with Wolfram as well how do we
take all that imagery and be able to say
you know this is an image of President
Obama saying what a terrible tragedy
versus this is an image of a building
down and specifically be able to detect
for example you know what what is the
level of damage that we're seeing their
being able to map out in real time it's
a project with us to two piece what's
happening around the world be able to
literally put images in the map and be
able to show networks of connectivity
what's happening anywhere on the planet
right now on this is a math will be
coming out soon tracking global refugee
shipment are out of the global refugee
movement through news me and did another
piece on a wildlife crime so all the
things that can be done from this and I
won't touch too much on this but
forecasting can be very interesting this
is a very very simple example of this
took Ukraine right before the president
fled took basically made essentially a
timeline of unrest looked across the
last 30 years from every country on what
are all the periods in the last 30 years
from any country that are most similar
overlaid those and then said well after
each of those period in the past what
happened after each of those periods
average those together and you actually
get something correlated about point 49
so red is what actually happened in
Ukraine Green is what happened in Turkey
in this period and in Lebanon average
those two together it's not a perfect
match but you actually gets really
interesting up/down behaviors here so
this is a really fascinating way of kind
of saying you know there are their
cycles of world history and again this
is a very primitive simple example using
pearson correlations what are all the
things that we can learn from all this
data and as a as a simple example so
something they'll be there will be now
shortly so working with Internet Archive
we've taken all the internet archive
digital book collection which is an
incredible collection all these amazing
books 1.5 million english-language
Americana books from 1800 to 19 20 30
and right now these these are all
separate PDF just sitting in this
archive so we've done now is we're
pulling all those in and processing all
those extracting other people
organizations locations themes emotions
etc and putting all those in the Google
bigquery database platform so you can
literally do a single query and search
across all that um this is a very simple
one this is 1800 all the locations
mentioned these books in the Year 1800
here's 1860 and here's 1899 so we can
see the western expansion you can see
what's interesting you can then
topically orient that and say where were
people what were people talking about
with respect to each of these locations
and then this is me and if you go to GTL
project or you can see a lot more about
this work and yell thank you very much